Yay!
We're going straight in.
I had no intro.
I just went straight in.
You just opened up on the game.
Wow.
Just like, raw.
That's it.
That's usually what happens in Collapse.
I just go straight in.
At that point, I stop putting an intro.
It reminds me of when I was like a Camelist streamer and I would literally hit the go live button on the game title screen and there was like no fanfare whatsoever.
Yeah, it was just here.
It's time to give.
Yeah.
The reason why Snuffy sounds like she's dead inside is that we literally woke her up from a Discord call.
You don't need to be rude, chat.
Some people think it's attractive.
The reason Snuffy has sexy morning voice is because...
And though some people is Lime.
Alright, so we just need...
Oh yeah, Snuffy, I need you to appear online for like one second.
Oh yeah, yeah, okay.
So I can get you in the lobby.
After months of staying offline, I risk it all for this.
Just for this.
Don't know you're alive now, you're now back on the grid.
It happens to me too.
Like, I just hide offline forever and then people are like, no, you have to be online.
It's like, but...
You have to be online.
That's why I'm hosting, so I don't have to be online.
But then no one will know when I'm playing my porn games if I'm not online.
You don't even have massage.
What's Orc Massage?
That's not the only game.
But it's your game.
That's your game.
That's not my game, it's the people's game.
I don't know why they're twerking, Emo.
Like, my guy looks like he's like...
It's okay, Snuffy, neither have I.
We just spent, like, the last ten minutes, like, finding stupid things to put on our characters.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's nobody to blame.
We literally spent money.
We bought skins.
What?
I didn't even see that.
I got scammed because I'm...
Welcome to the default redhead.
What?
You guys look like my cool babs and I look like I'm a green...
Hey, look, my pet rat.
Do you like my pet rat over here?
We're the dads and our twin daughters.
The gay dads and our twin daughters.
The gay dads and then, like, you got the hipster daughter over here and then the one that turned to religion, apparently.
She looks like she should be in, like, an Irish pub.
Canadian, eh?
Oh, wait!
And then we all moved to Canada.
Wait, you got a rat?
Yeah!
Yeah, she had a rat, too.
She looks after her cooler father.
Okay, you guys cannot look at me and say that I'm not the cooler father.
Look at me!
Yes, you can!
I'm literally a fucking ex-Hollywood star!
What do you mean an ex-Hollywood star?
It says, Sam, washed up Hollywood star.
Loves John Wayne movies and Satan.
Hates most people.
Wait, he loves Satan?
Why is he...
No one cares about an ex-Hollywood star.
Oh, you care.
You fucking are the other gay dad.
Wait, okay, hold on.
I might join a cult one day instead of going into work.
I've been in a cult!
I'm a competitive eating champion!
Oh yeah, that's why they said I'm the cooler dad.
Wait, I need to put my alphabet back on.
Yeah.
Is this pre-cult or post-cult?
This is post-cult and I own the cult.
I'm co-own the cult and these are the two children we had that we did not steal into our family.
That we didn't indoctrinate into the cult.
How come I don't look anything like you?
So, like, basically this is what Tom Cruise wishes you.
I don't think he wants to be a washed up actor though.
That's true, other than that part.
Okay, I bought my outfit so I don't feel like such a freaking plebian with you guys.
I am now...
Oh yeah, yeah.
You have a lot of hair.
It's so good!
Oh yeah, Min, you're apparently really...
Oh, well, we're gonna be using in-game volume though, guys.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So if she's too low, I'd have to fix her right now, cause...
You can't fix me.
I don't think she's ever fixable.
I don't think...
I don't...
Are we all ready?
Yeah.
I think so.
I wanted to be the short girl, but she didn't have any cool outfits, really.
So I was kinda sad about that.
So we have player collision is on, proximity voice is on, batteries are on, and medkits are on, and perks are...
I don't know what the perks are, but they're also on, so...
We don't have any, cause we have never played the game.
Oh, that's true.
So we're going straight in, with like, everything possible.
So...
We've never played this game, I'm not sure what we're capable of, but...
It's gonna be great.
We're gonna do great.
There's an objective, and also make sure you have voice enabled.
I'm gonna mute Discord now.
Yeah, me too.
Okay.
Alright.
I believe in us.
Can you guys hear me okay?
Yeah.
Wait, let me see...
Let me see, can we like, turn people, maybe we can turn people up in game, right?
I'm just turning down the music and the sound effects, and I'm turning up the game.
Oh, wait, I forgot you could do that.
Right.
Okay, music, sound effects, and then...
I'll turn up the game more.
Alright.
Should be good.
Okay, is this better?
Alright, guys, can you guys hear?
Can you guys hear me?
Yeah, I can hear you guys fine, because I turned everything but the voice chat volume down preemptively.
Okay, I'll turn the music just a little bit down, because I don't want to hear the wedding...
That wedding thing for like the hundredth time.
Oh my God, we've been listening to this song forever.
I can't.
Alright, guys, I'm readying it up now.
We're gonna go on a vacation, children.
With your new dads.
Yay!
I think one of our sons is like, our age.
No, he just works outdoors a lot.
Is this like my childhood baseball uniform I've been wearing since I was ten?
We've been telling you, you don't...
We've been telling you that you haven't aged past ten, so you think you're still ten years old.
Like, don't worry, it's your tenth birthday again.
Yay!
Get away from presents from Santa.
You wanna sit on Santa's lap?
If I was his other costume, it was a Santa outfit, actually.
No way.
I don't know if he does unfestive ones, but he can be Santa.
Oh my God, no, you're right.
Wait, so much hat.
No, she's Benjamin Button.
She's Benjamin Buttoning it right now.
This outfit.
Benjamin Button was based off of our son.
The real story.
It's the real story.
I need you to ready up.
Oh, sorry.
I'm ready.
I turned down my sound effects and brought up the game volume.
Let me know it's better.
There we go, guys.
Let me know if the volume is okay and everything.
England?
She's giving me super Miss Havisham vibes.
Azazel.
Yeah, this is a new level.
Ooh.
Azazel.
Why are we a fellow cult member?
Waiting for the host.
Hello.
Wait, how do I turn...oh, there you go.
Jesus.
Hello.
Hello, guys.
Guys, just so you guys know, our flashlight has batteries.
Just so you guys know.
Wait, oh my gosh.
The...
Gameplay, maybe?
Sensitivity is so low, it's fucking impossible to see you guys without it.
Yeah, I know.
It's alright.
If our flashlight dies, it dies.
Oh, wait, no, that's UV.
Oh, no, the UV requires batteries.
Wait, what's our UV?
Oh, so the flashlight is blue?
Oh, the right click.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The right click.
You know when we burn the zombies...the monsters out?
Burn the ghost?
And we go...
Have you played this live?
Wait, Snuffy's not alive yet.
Snuffy's...Snuffy's like...
Snuffy is tracking the...
No, no, sorry.
I was turning my light on.
Is it because you're scared?
It's because I need good VTuber tracking.
Don't worry, son.
If you stick with your daddy, you'll be fine.
Shut up!
It's our Halloween costumes!
What is this purple thing we're doing?
What is that?
It's when there's a demon that comes at you.
By the way, that's limited battery, but...
Oh, it's doing, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, it like recharges.
I think.
We need five batteries for it.
I figured it out.
Okay.
But like, it's used to chase away the monsters.
So when we go to this house, there's gonna be an objective...
I don't know if they like start the objective when we're...
I don't know.
When we find something.
Apparently they changed the game a little bit from this one.
Apparently this is like different from the previous ones too.
Hold on, I got this.
I don't know about you guys, but my character is fucking incapable of jumping.
She's like so heavy or something.
Wait, I think that's your rats.
Oh my god, I see your rats!
They're walking around at your feet!
I literally have no, like, HUD in this game.
So it just really looks like a bunch of dads trying to like...
That is us, that is us.
Don't worry, I'll be here to pick you.
I'll be here to catch you.
Don't worry son, I'll catch you.
I'm gonna burn your rat.
What was that?
I heard a dog.
Oh, I got a medkit.
There's a crow on this basin, or fountain even.
I think he's an evil crow.
He has glowing eyes.
Wait, I think that's...
Oh wait, look!
It's the angels!
They turned down my sound effects.
I just got a pumpkin.
I think we have to destroy pumpkins.
Collect 60?
Ok, we are not collecting 60 pumpkins.
Are they fucking satanic pumpkins or something?
Probably.
Good job.
Oh, there's a dead person!
Oh, he's headless!
He's headless!
No head!
What?
Oh wait, where's his head?
Is this a headless horseman?
No, it's a priest.
Alright children, it's time for family photo everybody.
This is one of those photo ops where you stick your head in.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it's like a cut out.
Ok, I'll take the picture.
I'll take the picture.
Everybody say cheese!
Cheese!
How do I screenshot on...
Steam?
F12.
Oh, it worked!
Yay!
What a great start to our family vacation!
Wait, so is my light gonna die?
No, no, no.
Oh wait, there's a woman.
There's a woman here.
That's my wife.
Don't disrespect...oh, nevermind, that's a child.
Sorry, I got a little excited.
You have to differentiate, please!
I got battered.
Dude, is your rat useful?
Is he like a tool?
No, I think he just follows you.
Yeah, I think he just follows.
He's gonna...
I keep getting stuck on him.
He's gonna rat you out.
He's gonna like...
Yeah, I wonder what happens if you had a pig and you just have a giant ass pig following you around.
Yeah, probably.
That'd be pretty awesome.
It was over this way before you ran off after the bodies, I think.
And we just walked away to look at dead bodies.
I mean, we had to get a family photo.
Probably.
The family photo was important, guys.
It's really funny because you literally like 180'd away from a dead body right here to go look at the other one.
Oh, this one's so cute!
She is?
That's your dead wife.
That's my dead wife, everybody.
I think it's a camera.
She's holding a camera.
It was her favorite thing.
In the bedroom.
Don't turn your black lights on around me, guys.
There's another body here, even.
Is that another lady?
I think we killed the chef.
Oh, is that the chef?
It looks like a chef out there, right?
Why are they all beheaded?
Doorways are one people wide.
What?
We can't get in there.
Wait, you can't actually go in?
Oh, look, another body.
Yeah, the door is locked.
Oh.
Maybe there has to be a secret entrance somewhere.
Secret.
The first struggle, finding the fucking door.
I've never played these games, so I'm relying on you guys.
I've only played one or two.
Look, it's the Liza P protagonist.
Oh, hey!
He has a nice suit.
We both played Devoured, but apparently this map is different from the other Devour.
Oh, I think we parkour here, right?
Maybe up the tree?
Maybe.
I'm going.
Alright, guys.
I'm doing really dad things right now.
Watch this, children.
This is how you do it.
Learn from us.
I'm stuck.
I think I'm stuck.
Wait.
Wait, are you stuck?
Hold on.
Hold on, I'm dad-stuck.
The demon is like, being in there for us, and we just...
It's different from normal...
Wait.
Ok, there we go.
We did it!
But for what purpose?
Ok, I need to turn my sensitivity up.
My sensitivity is way too low.
I know!
I had to turn mine up to...
Ok.
I wonder how long it's going to take for one of us to get yoinked, and then it takes like 10 years for anybody else to notice.
There's a door!
How do we get in?
I think the bird has to do with it, right?
No.
Everybody is over here.
Help me, step-wife.
I'm step-stuck.
We found it!
Oh, you did?
We found the door!
Get over here, children!
I'm coming.
I'm here!
The door?
Dad?
Oh, here.
This opens.
Wait a minute.
Snuffy, do you want to be a brave boy today?
You're making Snuffy go first.
Do you want to be a man today?
This is where you earn your man card.
Morello.
I'm finally going to get a girlfriend.
Not with that pitch, you won't.
Ah!
The little rat is stuck.
Whose rat is that?
Oh my God, whose birthday is it?
Wait, there's a note.
Read it out for the class.
I can't believe it.
He's dead.
What the fuck?
Stop that.
How do you do that?
I got his voice right.
Press what?
Press the numbers.
Just the numbers.
Come on.
Oh my God.
I maybe kind of spent like a dollar on the Macarena.
I knew I should check this out.
Oh my God, it's Fortnite.
It's Fortnite.
He threw the rat into it.
Oh my God, he's really into it.
He got Macarena into it.
I picked up a piece of cake, but I can't even interact with that.
He really needs an item.
I picked up a bottle and I don't know what to do with it either.
Also, I'm not going to talk into Macarena.
Oh, I just moved.
I think this is a pumpkin, right?
I don't know.
This guy wrote sin in my comic sans with also blood.
He drew a heart in blood.
Can you bring yourself up a little bit in game?
You're a little quiet for me.
Is this better?
Maybe a little bit more.
I don't know.
How do I do it in game?
I'm just raising my mic.
I think it's a lot better.
Maybe because I have to be close to you.
We're in London, everybody.
I'm ready.
I saw the tunnel.
It's okay.
I can fix this.
I've seen the ritual to summon Azazel.
I think I can do it.
I'll make him open a portal to the realm of the dead.
Then I'll find Michael there and we can be together again.
Oh, sorry.
I just made the sacrifices.
Heads would be best.
I love how that's like a Professor Layton English voice.
It's very good.
This reminds me of a puzzle.
Oh no.
How many demons put away the books?
The portal of the dead!
I don't like it in here.
Ouch!
I'm dying!
Don't stand there.
Got a pumpkin.
Do we need to be in the blue world?
The ambience here.
There are people inside that door.
Yeah, I hear them crying.
Wait, you think it's the ghost?
Maybe.
Maybe we should go... I hear them on the other side.
This is like Stranger Things.
We are in the unknown.
Can you guys hear us?
We gotta get the flickering lights to communicate with each other.
Flickering lights?
Oh, there's another note here.
Oh, that's a bunch of names.
John, Jasmine, Hakeem, Nicholas, Eric, Tyra, Madison, Ashley, Christopher, Ellie...
That's it.
The upside down.
Wait, there's another mirror here.
Here.
I don't... Oh my god.
Wait, that door opens.
The lights started flickering in there.
I don't think we should go back.
Wait, what did you see?
What did you see?
I opened the door and then you left and then all the lights started flickering.
You opened the door?
There was a door.
I didn't go in.
Why did you open the door?
I needed my dad.
You're not supposed to touch anything.
That's the number one rule.
Don't touch anything.
I think we're in trouble.
What's wrong with the music?
The music is freaking out.
What did you do?
That's literally horror movie 101.
Maybe we should go back in.
Let's go back in.
Why would we be here if we're not meant to touch stuff?
You first.
Me first?
You're meant to touch everything.
Okay.
They're too baby.
Alright Lime, let's go.
Here we go.
You turned it back like you thought I would just ditch you in here.
That's okay.
Oh, hello.
It's this door I opened, but watch out for the tentacles.
Oh, there's lots of tentacles.
Okay.
Alright, it's time to go in.
There's a person.
Can we interact with her?
I cannot shut the door.
Someone else shut the door.
No, I think we're supposed to interact.
Alright, Snuffy.
Time for another big boy moment.
Go, Donkey!
You're the dad!
Don't you wanna be a man, Snuffy?
Go zap her with UV or something.
What just happened?
I did it!
Yeah, we're definitely not fucked for doing that or anything.
Nah.
Is this door open?
Stop talking to him like that!
There's another mirror in here!
I don't understand this at all, you guys.
We got cake, we got booze.
You good?
Yeah!
We're going back through.
Okay!
They just totally missed it.
Weeheeheehee!
Why do we need cake?
We got everything.
Oh my god, it really does.
It really does look like...
I don't understand what this painting means.
Yeah.
I literally just did the Power Wash sim today for Shrek DLC.
It just came out.
Oh, there's feathers too?
What is this game?
Oh, I was gonna do that next week.
Was it good?
Yeah, but you need to... Okay.
The Shrek swamp is literally the last level.
So you have to go through so much just to get to the swamp.
I literally cleaned for four hours.
Oh my god.
I'm a bad one person.
Four hours just to get to the swamp?
I banned a person.
Oh, I know you banned grass.
No, there's three levels.
I think there's... I don't know if there's more than three.
But the first level is Lord Farquaad's place.
The second level is literally the Shrek honeymoon house.
And then the third one is the swamp.
Forget it.
Oh wait, this is a battery.
Maybe Snuffy, since you were using it earlier.
How did you know about grass?
Oh, because grass came to my chat.
And everyone was like, rip grass.
He knows what he did.
Oh, that's just a medkit.
Let's go see what they're doing.
He's creepy.
Let's not look at him anymore.
What is?
Oh, he's like waddling in there.
Oh, nope.
Thank you.
Look at that.
There's a head.
Oh my god.
I think we have to burn it with the...
Yeah, yeah.
Burn it.
Wait, is he biting my fucking ankles?
What am I hearing dying?
What the fuck is that noise?
What was that?
Oh, he's over there.
He's having like vigorous ghost sex in the walls.
Follow the head.
Look, he's crying.
You're torturing him.
What if we double team him?
You get him from the front.
I get him from behind.
Alright, where did he go?
Where did he go?
He's trying to go.
He's trying to go back to his...
Oh, Noki!
What the fuck?
Oh god.
I don't know if you can burn her.
I think you can only... maybe when she's aggravated, right?
Maybe.
Oh, she... you cannot.
I don't think you're supposed to touch her.
Oh my god.
I'm going into the...
Yeah, I'm with you.
I'm with you.
Am I alone now?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright, well, we have to go back so we can get to the head.
What do we do with the cake and stuff?
Maybe it's like...
I have no idea.
No, I don't know.
Alright, is it fine?
Is it safe, Stealthy?
Guys, I hear growling inside the mirror.
Okay, the ghost is...
I'll go.
Oh!
Oh, okay.
Oh.
I think she's fine.
Yeah, let's just go follow the head now.
Let's just go, yeah.
Let's just leave...
Leave her to her own devices and all.
Oh, there she is!
There's the head!
Okay, follow her.
Follow the head.
Where are you gonna go?
I wouldn't advise touching her.
Where is he going?
It's going backwards.
Are we supposed to kill it?
I don't know.
Wait, can we kill this?
Oh, I killed it!
Oh.
Ouch!
My doggie!
Doggie!
Oh, wait.
What is wrong?
Are you guys okay?
Wait, can you...
Wait, can someone...
I don't know what happened!
You're not supposed to touch it!
Hold on, I left my medkit in there.
But I killed this.
You touched a lady.
She touched a woman.
No, I touched the tentacles again.
Oh, you gotta stop doing that.
The therapist told you, you gotta stop touching those tentacles.
I thought I killed them!
Man.
Wait, what did we do?
What did we do with the head guy?
He didn't seem to care that much.
No, he didn't really do anything.
Yeah, should we just follow the head?
We just follow it?
There's like a door that opened.
Oh, wait.
This door is open too.
Some of these doors weren't open before.
Oh, I wonder if we open them in the shadow, if it opens them here.
Oh, we're supposed to put the cake...
No, right?
We're supposed to put the cake back together.
On the plates, yeah.
That will stop the demons.
She knows it's like happy birthday!
Wait, I'm gonna go find a piece of cake and I'll come back through here.
Do we have any cake?
No.
Looks delish.
Oh, we need a kitchen key.
Someone was crying.
Oh, that's the front door.
We opened the front door.
That's cool.
Oh, nice!
Nice.
Oh, I found a key!
What did he say?
Hot sauce?
Where are you?
What?
Who's the children?
Where is everybody?
Hot sauce.
I got the kitchen key!
Where is everybody?
You're upstairs?
I think they're upstairs.
They're in the walls.
What is happening?
Oh, hello.
Where?
What is the children?
Oh, our children, yes.
Sorry, I forgot I was a father.
Here it is.
What, is this the closet?
Oh no.
Yeah.
We gotta go to the closet and the kitchen.
You decided this.
This is the real Devour experience though, truly.
Yeah, actually.
Alright, following you.
There was a closet door somewhere.
Oh, what is this though?
Oh, this is where the wedding happened.
Yeah.
Oh, this is the wedding?
Woah, ok, this looks really fucking scary.
Oh, there's the dead husband!
More dead lady?
Oh my god, it opens.
It's a development room.
Photographs.
I hear something nasty in here.
Oh, it's pictures of the deceased people.
Picture.
Oh, there's a pumpkin.
I say so, maybe do it.
After getting their heads back there.
Yeah.
This is complicated.
There's so much here.
It was like a little bacon.
I couldn't tell at all.
Yeah, it looked like a prune.
Oh.
The bride has like a flower crown, I guess.
I don't know.
I guess so.
Maybe like, maybe it's this guy.
Which one?
That guy, because I think like the other one.
Are we supposed to do something with the photos?
Maybe we're supposed to chase the head.
We're supposed to chase the head to the bodies.
Oh god.
I don't think so.
Then why the fuck would you do that?
I like the shuffle room.
Just the absolute...
Can you like put the soil back in?
Oh yeah, try and bury it.
I'm pretty sure we're supposed to bring the heads to there and then bury it.
How?
But he runs at random.
Oh there's another...
There's a maid!
Oh my god.
A ghost maid.
That's you.
That's you before you died.
This is literally me!
That's literally you!
Okay guys.
Bury me.
Bury me, doggie.
It's true.
Oh!
Lime got the downstairs bathroom.
Oh yeah, show me where the closet is.
Downstairs.
The kitchen key.
Yeah.
Since we opened this area, maybe the ghost will run here.
Maybe the ghost head will run here now.
Is this the groom?
Oh, pumpkin.
I just like collecting these.
Why are there so many dead...
There were not this many photos.
There were not this many photos of people.
Do you know where I work?
That would be so gross.
Imagine you die in a freaking bottle accident and you are buried there with a spatula in your hand.
Do we burn the bodies with alcohol?
Maybe.
I'm totally down for burning them.
Me too.
Oh, this is... okay.
We are back at the beginning.
We started that.
That's where we've been there.
That's where we started.
There is a grave here too.
Really?
This is where they summon Azazel.
Azazel.
This is where they found her.
We were here.
Yeah, that's what we were saying.
So we found a loop-de-loop.
Yeah, there is a little loop.
We found a loop-de-loop.
Okay, chat.
Is the volume better now?
Is my sound better?
Can you hear everybody?
I think this game's problem is this tunnel could collapse in a moment.
Are people too loud?
Wait, we can open the kitchen key.
Manhattan Kitchen.
Oh yeah, where is the kitchen?
Oh, we have a kitchen.
It is right here.
It will all make sense after we get into the kitchen.
Where?
Oh, right here?
Nice.
Good thing I didn't buy the pig.
He would've been so sad.
Wait, let's get to the other world.
Wait, there is the other world.
Yeah.
Alright.
I'm going in.
I'm going ghost.
Oh my god.
Is this safe?
It was like... Oh, there is a head in here.
He can't get out.
Hit him with the shovel.
Or let him out.
Why did you let him out?
Presumably we have to let them out to free them or some shit.
Maybe.
Walk your dog.
Go ahead.
Take him outside.
He went back into the kitchen.
Wait, what do you mean we are hurting them?
What is that sound?
What is that noise?
Yeah, she like hits her head on the wall and stuff.
She is kind of crazy.
He is right here.
Take him to the outside.
We got the outside door.
We should take him to the outside like a good dog.
Good dog.
Wait, why do we have two heads now?
Oh god.
Because we found two heads.
Yeah, there is like a second head.
Wait, try the cake.
Who has the cake?
Oh, I found a third head!
Oh my god.
Wait, they are meeting.
The dogs are meeting.
Let them sniff each other.
Let them sniff each other?
Yeah.
My dogs.
We are the worst dog walkers ever.
What's going on?
I think we are in trouble.
As long as we are here we will be fine, right?
I don't know.
Let's just hide in the kitchen.
Why did you get rid of your weapon?
It doesn't work!
Somebody said we should feed them cake.
Oh, feed them cake?
Yeah, they said to feed them cake.
Are you guys ok?
No.
No?
What happened?
Oh, she's in here.
Go, go, go!
I got you!
I got you, son!
Are you ok?
Live?
Oh, there you are.
She got better.
Do you want the cake, little guy?
Do you want it?
Oh yeah, give him the cake.
GG!
Baby!
Ok, there we go.
Oh my god, he's coming.
Little dog!
Go, go!
Go, go, go!
What does that mean?
I grabbed him!
I have the human!
I have the head!
You have the head.
I have him in my inventory.
I don't know.
The witch is in the real world now.
She came through the mirror and killed Snuffy and now she's out there.
And Snuffy is for some reason still alive.
Snuffy, can you go back through the mirror?
Do you die again?
No, I revived her.
I revived her.
Oh, ok.
You fucking disintegrated on my screen.
Ok, so there's bodies...
Ew, his spine is just like following you.
All we have to do is...
We have to go outside...
There's bodies outside so we piece those heads to that body.
Oh boy.
I think they're all the same head model.
Yeah, I think it doesn't matter who we do.
Ok, so we go back to the real world and find a grave.
Oh god.
Wait, everyone should grab a head.
Everyone should grab a head probably, right?
Yeah.
Uh oh.
I hear her.
Oh wait, here's a guy.
Here's a guy.
And... cake.
Wait, who has the shovel?
It's in the normal world.
The shovel is right here.
Ok, it's in the real world though.
Ok.
I'm gonna go put this in a body.
Yeah, that's what I'm gonna go do.
I'm scared of the lady though.
I'm scared of her.
Where?
Oh, the head must be cleansed before playing.
What the hell does this mean?
With alcohol maybe?
Maybe, let's try it.
This is so much.
Ok, there's like alcohol everywhere.
Yeah.
Oh my god, how much is there to do?
Oh, here's some.
Ok, put it in.
Alright.
If it can clean woods, it can clean heads.
Ok.
Oh, oh my god, I'm cleaning it.
I'm cleaning it.
I have a head.
She's a lady.
Oh, she's beautiful.
Who do I put this on?
So we can look at it.
Oh, wow!
Do you think that's a maid?
Wait, how do I grab it?
Oh, someone else grabbed it.
There you go.
It's ok.
For some reason it won't let me... Oh, there it is.
We need to go find her now.
Ok.
We can look at the pictures again.
There weren't that many pictures though.
There weren't that many pictures.
What if we... It's fine.
They don't care whose head they get.
Like, whatever.
Is she there?
Oh, ok.
Let's go this way.
Oh, nevermind.
Let's go.
We don't have stamina to jump.
Oh, we can't go out.
It's a one-way entrance.
Oh my god, ok.
She can only kill one person.
Did she leave?
Ok guys, come on, come on.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't have the key.
I'm gonna grab... Yeah, grab cake.
Grab anything you see.
There's another piece of cake here.
Oh, here!
Wait, who had the downstairs bathroom key?
Lime had it, right?
This one, this one.
This is the downstairs bathroom.
Yeah, one of the heads might be stuck in the bathroom.
There we go.
I should find where to put this one, though, before I get killed.
There is a cake in here.
And a ducky.
Oh, maybe it's in the ghost world?
Yeah, there might be a head in here.
There's another cake.
I'll grab it.
Oh, there's more alcohol in here.
Nice.
How do we get to the maid area?
It was like in the back of the house.
I think it's the maid.
It has to be.
Try putting it on this person.
Lime did.
Oh my god, so we actually have to guess?
No, it's in the photos, remember?
The photos that we saw there.
Yeah, but there weren't that many photos.
Is she there?
I think yeah.
Are you guys okay?
Oh, hello.
What's she doing?
She's crawling on her knees.
Hey there.
Are you okay, ma'am?
Relatable.
A week of hard work right there.
She's going up the corpse and it's freaking out.
This way.
A corpse?
Oh, it's winning its head!
Oh my god!
Is it the maid?
Bury me!
Run!
Hello?
Maybe we go to the mirror world.
Yeah, we all kinda split.
We scooby-dooed it.
I hear her screaming in there.
You think she's gonna stay aggro forever?
I can hear her freaking.
Oh, I hear her too.
Oh, maybe we should go.
Bird.
Is the bird indicative of anything?
Oh, it's coming!
Yeah!
It's an enemy!
Oh, there's a...
I have cake.
We gotta go to the other world.
Yeah, it was like hard to...
I don't know.
Are you guys dead?
I think we gotta go to the other world.
Like the mirror world.
Oh my god, she's really freaking out in there.
I don't wanna get jumpscared.
She's freaking me out.
I'm being a baby.
Oh shoot.
Lime!
Don't die!
Lime, are you dead?
Oh, OK.
This way!
Oh my god.
Are we OK?
Oh, I hear them!
What the hell is that?
What's going on?
Oh, I think she's back to normal.
I think she's back to normal!
No!
Watch out!
Behind you!
I didn't run away!
We were running together!
You left me!
What do you mean?
I said Lime, let's go!
I was begging you to use the flashlight on her!
Oh, I don't think it works, does it?
I didn't.
I stopped her with the flashlight when mine came back enough.
Oh, she's down the... Oh my god, that looks so scary.
Let's go to the other world.
I heard Snuffy and Doki down there.
Oh my god.
Lime, I'm going!
Hello?
I'm gonna grab this guy.
I do.
There you go.
Little guy.
Eat some cake.
Eat it.
Eat it on up.
Is Doki alive?
I kind of heard some voices earlier, so maybe.
Oh, that might have been me and Lime.
I thought she was with you.
Doki?
Wait, I see a flashlight!
I see a flashlight!
Hello?
Hi!
Are you guys good?
What do you mean, Doki?
She's like, in this hallway.
But she sounds like she's calm now.
Did you guys chill her out?
I used the UV light on her.
Oh, okay.
So, like, we clean a bunch of heads and then drop... put it in the altar after we clean them.
So then, like, you know how when we put the head to the body, they get angrier?
So all we have to do is just, like, have a pile of clean heads at the altar.
Okay.
I have a head currently.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
Come with me.
I cleansed... I have alcohol already.
Oh, okay, okay.
To the altar.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Come here.
Alright.
I'll grab this one, too, just cause...
Yeah, yeah.
We can head downstairs.
Alright, alright, alright.
Downstairs.
Alright.
I thought the cake would make them sleep.
I dropped a head in the tomb, by the way, because I didn't realize it would run.
I think she only gets aggroed...
I think she only gets aggroed once we bury the body.
So we can probably attach the heads and then go around and bury the body.
Oh, that's true!
That's true!
Yeah, we can do that.
I'll fill it up again, too.
I think a little guy just escaped.
There's a head walking around.
Yeah, no, that was me.
I didn't realize he starts moving.
Oh, yeah, you gotta cleanse him.
After I dropped him, I thought I could just put him there.
Wait, let's grab him.
Where is he?
I don't have a cake, though.
Oh, we need more cake!
Yeah, yeah, we need more cake.
Boys!
Oh, no!
Oh, but...
Subby, Subby, Subby!
Wash his head!
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, that's the cook!
This is the cook!
This is the cook?
Yeah, we can attach.
I'm just thinking when we attach them, do you think they'll run away because they're vibrating?
No, they're chained down!
I got John Alpha male over here.
John Alpha?
John Alpha male.
What does he look like?
Oh my god!
Oh, wow!
Maybe the groom, then?
Maybe.
Yeah, yeah, that could be the groom.
Oh, she's gonna get excited!
Whoa!
You're gonna be all...
Let's make a circle of heads.
We're gonna induce more trauma than like a ghost already has.
It looks like the start of...
You wanna just leave them here until we're ready?
Maybe they can kiss.
Make them kiss.
Wait, how do you hold it?
Who's a bigger freak?
Us or the ghost?
I'm literally just like collecting severed heads.
I'm playing Barbie dolls with it.
I'm playing Barbie dolls with the head.
Oh, this one head over here is like gagging.
Yeah, he's still waiting for it.
He's pouting, he's like in the corner like, I'm upset.
We're chasing him back into the...
Go back!
Oh my God.
Chase him back!
Oh, he got out.
He got out.
We have one job.
Okay, I'm back here I guess.
Me too.
Wait, is she in this world or the other?
I can't tell.
I can't tell either.
I never know.
I'm just scared forever.
Is it really loud?
I think she's in the inside world.
I think she's in the real world.
Where's Naimo?
Did she die?
Hello?
I just watched Doki die.
Oh, that sucks.
What killed her?
The ghost lady.
But we can probably get a medkit and bring her back, I think.
Oh, there she is.
Hi Doki!
In the other world?
That's so sad.
Oh, you got a medkit.
Nice.
We're gonna run out of medkits.
I'm scared.
Two of them were me.
Oh my god, I got the head.
I was nearly against the mirror and then she fucking jumped out from the mirror.
Yeah, I know.
I was right there.
You watched it happen.
Yeah, I literally watched it happen.
How do we get to the...
I got one of them.
Got her.
Wow, she sounds a little...
You did that.
At least she's having a good time.
You didn't complain.
Oh, nice.
Oh, wait.
I thought we were waiting.
I think if we put the heads on, it's okay.
She aggroes when we bury the body.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, they're fine like that.
Probably.
This head does not belong here.
I'm gonna go to the back and see if I can find...
There was this one, right?
Oh my god, I got him.
I got him.
It was the groom.
I almost said the broom.
Wait, do you guys...
I got the groom.
Yeah, it was the groom.
I don't see him.
Wait, I don't see him.
He's right over here.
Oh, there he is.
Look at him.
He doesn't say anything.
Oh, he does.
He's just very quiet.
Yeah, he's just like... He's whimpering a little bit.
Whimper a little bit.
Oh, I found more cake.
Oh, nice.
Wait, we need that so we can get that guy.
The one in...
There's three slices in here, actually.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, okay.
But we'll aggro her.
Yeah.
Me too.
Where's the one... Where's the head that's in here?
He's over here, right?
No, we had one here, right?
Right here.
I got him, I got him.
Yeah, remember?
We were telling you.
I think we accidentally brought him here and then when you dropped him down and...
Oh my god, Doki.
You're taking this old man roleplay way too far.
Okay.
Okay, we have alcohol.
Oh, yeah.
Put it in.
I got the alcohol.
Alright.
I have extra too.
My early onset dementia.
Look, I'm old right now.
I'm playing an old cat.
I'm just roleplaying.
I'm just roleplaying as the old man.
Look at him squirm.
Oh, it's so gross.
Do you think Snoopy's dead over there?
Wait, dead?
Snoopy's dead.
Wait, what did she do?
What happened?
Snoopy!
Oh, I wonder if it was a bat or a crow.
Oh, I have the lady!
I have the lady in the backyard.
I'm gonna go put her on.
Hi!
Hello.
What happened?
You're like really groaning.
I can't tell.
I don't know where she is.
Yeah, yeah, I got her.
I'm scared.
Yeah.
I got alcohol.
Do you think we can hide in here and she'll come?
Okay, okay.
Yeah.
She's upstairs?
I don't think it stops her.
Oh, it did stop her.
She's like still around, but she's not pissed.
She's back to normal.
Oh here we go, here we go.
There you go.
Okay.
Oh!
Here it is!
Oh my god.
We have two cakes for...oh shit, there's a crow.
We have two cakes for a head, so we gotta go to the other world.
Yeah, let's go to the other world.
There's one...the one that I tripped and fell is upstairs.
Oh, I hear her crying.
She's in the ghost world.
Oh, okay.
Watch out for the...
I have cake.
Did we get all of them in here?
This one...
Did we get all the heads?
Any head?
Any head around?
Guys, I really don't want to be jump scared.
I'm gonna turn down the volume a little bit.
Sound effects, maybe?
I had to turn it up, because I turned everything up.
What's going on?
Oh, whoa, be careful, be careful.
Don't die to that.
Oh, you can't go down there in this world.
Yeah?
What about me?
How many heads we got?
Hello?
Do you have the upstairs bathroom key?
Maybe?
Yeah, I'm pretty sure we got it.
It's up here.
Where?
In here?
Right side, right side.
No, no, no, right side.
Here, here.
Here?
The door over here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Left, left.
Right here.
Oh, here?
Oh, no.
I don't have it.
Oh, you did.
Oh, what?
I remember you had an upstairs something.
I have a kitchen and closet.
I have the closet key.
Oh, okay.
I have cake if we need another head tonight.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Do we have another head?
I have cake also.
I've never seen one.
How many have we had so far?
Four, maybe?
I'm holding one right now, so...
I'm gonna go to the other world to clean this one, though.
No head?
Where'd your head go?
Where's your head at?
Alright.
Kitchen?
I feel like we should get one more at least.
I feel like so, too.
Do you know... Wait, you know where the closet was, didn't you?
Yeah, it was at the bottom.
The closet was at the bottom.
I don't think I unlocked it.
It's down here.
Or did I?
It's open on this side, but it might not be open on the other side.
Oh, wait.
I think I did.
Never mind.
I did open it.
Oh, that's a bad word.
Wow!
All the YouTube streamers demonetized!
Oh my god!
Oh, I hear her banging her head.
There's gotta be... We gotta get the other keys then, I think.
Maybe.
I'm gonna grab this medkit instead of the cake.
Just in case.
I'm following live.
I know, right?
She's fine, I think.
There's more alcohol in here.
No?
What did you say?
What?
Oh my god!
No way!
Oh my god.
What?
The crows take the head if you don't bury them.
Well, that makes sense.
Do you think there will be crows taking the head at the altar then?
Maybe we should just...
Just like stockpile heads at the altar.
It's really easy to calm her down, so we just calm her down.
Yeah, let's calm her down real quick.
Wait, that just lifted up.
Yeah, she did that earlier.
Oh really?
Is she coming this way?
Where is she?
Oh no.
Here she is.
Yeah, calm down.
Little bride, go back to sleep.
What?
This doesn't concern you, dude.
Yeah, get out of here.
You don't need to be here.
Go away.
Let's put the head... Wait, does that...
I think they will still grab them though, right?
Even if we...
Stock...
I'm gonna go bury them.
Ok, she's gonna aggro.
She's gonna aggro.
What the?
Wait, what?
What just happened?
I don't know.
She didn't aggro.
Oh, nevermind.
Goddammit.
I spoke too soon.
Ok, you're ready to beam her?
Yeah, we got her.
Light her up.
This is the light her up section.
Wait!
Come here, come here.
Oh my god!
I think...
Where are you?
Wait, where did Snuffy go?
I can heal her.
The UVA pissed her off that time.
I think it's supposed to get harder as the game goes on.
No, it is.
It is.
The more heads we're returning, the more power she unlocks.
Where is Snuffy?
We have to go to the other world.
Ok, let's stockpile heads in the altar.
Can you pick up this head?
We'll put all the heads in the altar and then we'll start...
There's no way the crows will head to the altar.
Yeah, true, true.
It's our safe place.
The crows can't go in because there's God on our side.
Azazel is on our side, actually.
I thought you loved Satan.
You don't love God, you love Satan.
Wait, who took the other head?
Oh, you have it?
No, Lime has it.
I think she went to stockpile it.
I see Snuffy, I'm gonna go heal her.
Snuffy!
I'm coming for you!
My savior!
Oh, sorry.
Wait, how do I heal you?
Press E.
Oh, E?
Hold it down.
Oh, it's not working.
Oh, there we go, there we go.
Oh, ok.
I might wanna run.
She is so rude!
I can't see anything with this flashlight.
Yeah, let's just go to the crypt.
How many bodies do we have left?
She was like, I'm gonna get you guys again.
And then she just broke my neck.
She's like, oh, you guys win.
Just kidding.
Yeah, she was pacified and then she went, haha, that's a joke.
And actually just murdered Snuffy.
Yeah, I think it only stuns her now.
It doesn't actually pacify her.
We'll stockpile all the heads in this quarter.
It'll be fine.
We just need to find more heads.
I have not seen five heads.
There's no way.
There's a lot of bodies.
I've never seen that many heads.
They're all just trapped in one bathroom.
Serious, actually though.
Ok, you're not safe in the other world either, everybody.
Red eyes can't be stunned.
She doesn't have red eyes.
The lore, the...
I hear her screaming.
Yeah, that's when you know she's extra Bridezilla.
Should we go into the other world?
I guess.
That's her outside.
Help!
Shine!
I found a head!
There's a head guy right here!
There's another head.
Does anybody have cake?
I don't have cake.
Ok, time to find cake.
You found some?
No, I found alcohol.
Did I just hear her?
They got this head.
I'll take it to the altar.
Was that the head from the altar?
No, this is not the one from the altar.
Ok.
It better not be.
Wait, they can come in here though, don't they?
We've zapped them from in here before.
But this is a different head, but they can definitely come in here.
Yeah, but there's no way they can find it.
There's no way.
This is our quarter.
It's our safe space.
We gotta find...
We gotta find cake.
Oh, what the...
It's literally you!
Yeah, we all do.
We all know.
What's this?
Oh, upstairs bathroom key.
Dang it.
Three cakes?
Wait, where's another cake?
Get the head.
Where is it?
Where's the cake?
Oh, is there any more cake?
Ok.
Ok, go get a head.
Oh, I found cake too!
Ok, I'm also gonna go get head.
Oh.
I'm kinda trapped in my location.
Oh, I think she's on the other side.
Oh my god!
Holy...
God!
I didn't even turn it down!
I saw my flashlight going.
I should've known.
You know what?
I know there's an option for like...
They're like, this is for the not faint of heart.
There's no point in having the jump scare sound on.
Oh, there's a health kit.
I'll go right next to it.
The real jump scare going deaf.
That's what I'm saying.
Oh, there's lots of cake and there's a med kit here.
Can you guys hear my guy?
Oh gosh.
Thank goodness I didn't have my headphones on yet.
I'm so sorry everybody.
I didn't think I was being that loud.
I didn't even turn it down.
Do you think they'll find me over here?
There's so much in here.
There's cake, there's a med kit, there's booze.
I got all I need.
A little ear damage as a treat.
Are they even still alive?
I don't hear them.
This is me when I stub my toe.
Oh my god.
The way she screams is crazy.
Where is she?
Are they still alive?
Where are they?
Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna die out here.
I'm gonna die out here like Ryan Reynolds in Blade Runner.
You'll need to stun her multiple times to calm her down now.
Just make sure to run when she's stunned.
Got it.
Hello?
I know where the med kit is.
Oh, I said Ryan Reynolds.
Wrong Ryan.
Wait, there's a med kit in here.
It's right here.
And there's lots of cake and stuff in here too.
There you go.
Got you.
Someone in my chat said we'll have to stun her multiple times now to calm her down.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And more cake as well.
Check the bodies for the bathroom key, bro.
How do we open this door?
Oh, she's right there.
Oh my god.
I don't deserve to be alive.
I really don't deserve to be alive.
Here, let's go.
We can go through.
Let's see.
Any head?
Oh, where are you, Lime?
Oh, hi Stumpy.
We're trying to find heads, I guess.
Oh yeah, me too.
These things suck.
I think they're all trapped behind that one...
baby.
You're so cute being sad about something.
What's she being so sad about?
More cake in here.
What if the last key is like gated behind actually like burying the bodies or something?
It could be.
I hope not.
Unless we just had the bathroom key and nobody knew.
Yeah, did everyone try opening it?
I've tried opening it.
Yeah, me too.
This is an actual mirror?
Wow, crazy.
Wait, I thought it was one too.
I was like, oh, our escape route.
I can't stop thinking...
Oh god.
No.
I think she's still in the real world.
Oh my god.
Oh, here she comes!
Stun her, stun her!
Ok, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Just run.
Yeah, yeah.
I think she's gonna come out.
We're gonna have to...
She's where?
Where is she?
Come here!
Oh.
No, we couldn't find any.
I think she's stupid.
Oh, there she is.
Double kill.
Oh, we got her, we got her, we got her, we got her.
Yeah.
No, I think it's true though, because once we started burying things, we got more heads, so...
I'm buried though.
I got a lady.
Ok, where's Snuffy?
Where is Snuffy?
Wait, I'm gonna get the flower lady.
Actually, no.
I know where the flower lady goes.
I'll get this one.
I don't know where this lady goes, but I'll figure it out, because...
Snuffy!
Wait, do you... Wait, Doki, do you know where...
Oh, ok.
Snuffy?
Oh, there's Snuffy.
Ok.
Oh, I found mine!
Oh, mine's right here!
Mine's right here!
Snuffy!
I've got one too.
I've got one too once you're done.
Ok, so... Snuffy, this way?
This way?
What is it?
Oh, it's a key!
There's a lady right here that needs to be buried!
Right there!
We'll protect you!
Oh, she... Ah, it's at the head!
Oh, watch out!
I don't think we're gaming.
I got one!
Ouch!
Oh, wait, where is it?
Ok, I'll do it.
Um, we gotta save.
Yeah, cause she killed Doggie.
Yeah...
Where's the bird?
Ow!
Oh my god.
I hear him.
Yeah, get his ass.
Ok.
Uh, how do I... How do I dig?
Oh my god!
I got it?
Ok, you try digging.
Ok.
Oh, it's on the dirt pile.
That's why.
Ok, ok.
I'm silly.
Sorry.
Nice.
Oh, we're halfway there!
Yeah, I think that's a good idea.
Wherever front is.
Ah, shit.
Oh, welcome back!
It's this way!
Oh, ouch!
I know.
Oh, I have a battery.
There's a battery right here.
You can use it.
Run!
Run away from her!
Oh god.
Did she... Did she just... Oh.
Oh my god, and the bird.
Ok.
Uh, does anyone have the shovel?
Ok, there we go.
Ok, I got a medkit, so I guess I'll go... I'll go save Stuffy.
Who's laughing?
Oh, I know.
That's my character celebrating because she's a freak.
Oh.
Oh god.
If I die, I have a medkit.
Just take it if I die.
Ok.
Time to go save Snuffy.
Oh, there's Snuffy.
There's my son.
I got you, son!
Son!
Oh, son!
Son, I don't got you, son.
Son.
Son, I'm sorry, son.
Son, I'm sorry!
Hello.
I might have left... led her there to here.
I don't know.
Oh, son!
I got you, son.
We probably should have waited until she was not aggroed anymore.
No way!
I'm so proud of you.
Literally, as I was saying...
Oh my god.
She's crawling again.
I have this.
Do we want to go bury it?
Ok.
I'll grab a cake.
Is that her?
Oh no, that's a bird.
No, she's not.
Oh god!
Ok.
Ride!
I'm running!
Go to the other world!
Oh shit!
Oh no!
No!
I think I'm next, guys.
I can't tell if she's aggroed anymore or not.
I have no more battery.
I think I'm...
I haven't found anymore...
I ate that pasta for breakfast.
She's immediately coming.
She's in this world, right?
Absolutely.
I always get stuck behind the door.
I still don't see any heads in the other world.
Me neither.
Oh!
Oh no!
Not alive!
I'm stuck on the door!
Doki?
I think...I don't think we are going to get this.
Are you ok?
This is bullshit.
Welcome to devour experience.
I don't see any heads.
That was just a bunch of this all over the place.
I found a head!
What are you talking about?
I was literally right in front of it.
You know what?
I'm going to die so that you have to do everything by yourself.
She's coming.
Oh, this is not a real mirror.
Doki, you died on purpose, didn't you?
No!
You died on...oh.
I'm colliding with the ghost.
I can't get inside.
She's my wife!
There is no way.
There is no way I can do all of this by myself.
It's literally impossible.
It's literally impossible!
Everybody is dead?
Oh god, everybody is converging here.
I'll join you here!
OK, block her!
Block her!
Body block her!
Body...oh shit!
Oh my god, we got an achievement left for dead.
Lost a game.
Love that that's an achievement when it's like the default for this game.
We were getting devoured.
Guys, we kind of got bodied.
Oh my god.
I'm so sorry.
We didn't survive.
It's OK, guys.
She's spawn camping me.
OK, I'm gonna turn off player collision.
I'm turning off batteries and I'm turning off medkits.
Well, no, I think turning off batteries is bad because our flashlight is still refilled.
But the batteries added more to it, so turning off batteries would be worse.
Yeah, maybe?
Would medkit mean we don't have any meds at all?
Yeah, no, you want to keep those on.
OK, so everything is the same.
Alright, we can make it easier, by the way.
Oh, survive?
OK.
OK, well, I think I get it, right?
I think I get the hang of it now.
You got it, right?
Yeah, we have the system now.
We know what to do.
Yeah, we figured it out.
It just took a long time.
It just took multiple medkits.
Oh my gosh.
Two of those were mine.
I'm so sorry.
Because of the damn tentacles.
Two of them were me.
How's that?
I know this is way late, guys, but how is the audio?
I feel like I'm too loud, but Doki said I needed to be louder.
It's good.
Yeah, Doki does have some kind of noise gate.
I don't know.
It's kind of funny, though.
Oh, hello?
Hello?
Moshi moshi!
Oh, I'm alive.
No way!
Moshi moshi!
I like to be immersed.
I like to sympathize with the ghost.
What are you talking about?
Come on!
I know this has been leaking, but can you use the volume okay, guys?
Oh, yeah, your audio is all fucked, Doki.
That's why I'm asking.
If it's bothering you, you can turn the jumpscares off.
Yeah, it's really loud.
Don't feel bad about it.
Let's get ready to do the fastest fucking run of our lives.
We gotta make sure we grab all the keys, though.
Wasn't there... This one spawned here.
It wasn't here originally.
Oh, maybe it's different.
Maybe it spawns more when we grab more keys.
Oh wait, are you serious?
Oh my god, you're right.
They have different spots.
No!
The people?
The bodies?
Yeah.
This is a speedrunner's worst nightmare.
Why would they do this?
Speedrun a haunting.
This was the redhead.
Oh wait, was it the redhead?
I think so.
This is how we get in over here, though.
Lime is so fast.
No, you're good.
You're good.
Oh, you can't kill the crows yet.
What door?
What'd I open?
Oh yeah.
Yeah, then I'll do it again.
Wait, let's grab cake first, right?
Let's find some cake first.
Yeah, that seems... I think so too.
Here we go!
Oh, watch out.
Don't... Oh no!
Oh my god.
See?
It's so easy to step in it.
Upstairs?
I think it was upstairs.
Maybe I'm crazy.
I feel like...
Oh yeah, yeah.
It was this one.
Alright, daughter.
What?
It's time to be a woman.
Oh, that's what it feels like.
Yeah, I get jump scared.
You guys just have the lights turned on.
We gotta get keys now.
We gotta get keys.
Keys and heads.
The strats.
Maybe the key will... Maybe the key is spawned outside.
Because we opened the doors.
Painting room key.
Ok.
Where is she?
Maybe everybody is not in this world.
I can't... Oh, she is in this world.
Nevermind.
Just kidding.
I'm leaving.
Oh, I just found the painting room.
Wait, I know where the painting room is.
I'm in the painting room right now.
You were in there?
No, I was just over there.
Oh gosh.
How do I get back?
Can you open the painting room though?
I know.
I saw it.
I was literally just there.
How do we get there?
I don't remember.
It was through here.
It was... It was...
It's like back here, right?
Here, here, here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Little head.
Oh, head, head, head!
Come, come, come, come.
I'm grabbing him.
Come on, little guy.
Oh, you got him.
Nice.
What was that?
Oh, thank you.
The cake can be used multiple times.
Yeah.
No.
He doesn't need it.
He's a skinny guy.
Skinny legend.
Excuse me.
Sorry.
We're both very wide bodied.
Any skinnies?
Any skinnies in here?
Little guys?
Wait, this is the painting room.
Any skinny guys?
Yeah, we're big boned.
Any skinnies?
I think I hear her children.
More cake.
What's in here?
Oh, I don't think I've ever even been in here before.
What's this?
Oh, children.
Wait a second.
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm in here.
Wait, where am I?
Guys, I'm so lost.
Friends and the family.
The bones.
I'm gonna go down and out to that one room.
Or out here.
By the fountain, because there was a key over here.
I wonder if it respawned, you know?
Broad shoulder...
I got the closet.
That's nice.
Am I Australian?
Crikey.
This isn't the closet, is it?
More cake.
There's gotta be a head in here.
Nothing.
Where did everybody go?
How am I so by myself?
I'm scared.
What?
Hi.
Yeah, me too.
But I couldn't find anybody.
I just opened these doors and there was nothing in here.
Anyone in here?
Rubber ducky?
Dingo, wipe me baby.
Dingo, wipe your baby.
I never seen that movie.
There's a closet right here.
Where's the closet key?
Somebody has it, I remember.
I got a cake.
You grabbed my last guy, so I...What the hell?
No!
I just want one head, please!
Just want one head.
Is there any head in here?
Oh wait, there used to be.
Wasn't there a mirror there?
The mirror locations changed too?
You guys, I have no head.
No from Seinfeld.
I thought it was a movie.
Someone pick an alcohol for me.
Alcohol?
Ok, I got it.
Oh, watch out, watch out.
Get the birds.
Alright.
I don't believe that anyone has beaten this game before.
Until now.
We will be the first VTubers who beat this game.
We'll be the first anybody to beat this game if we can.
Ok, I'm here waterboarding the head now.
I know.
Why do we put it face down like this?
Oh my god!
There's a little baby head!
Yeah, it's the ring boy.
I feel like this looks like...You know how in Minecraft you can arrange people's heads?
Wait, he just grabbed one!
That's fine, it's just one guy.
Yeah, but they'll keep grabbing them.
Yeah, but they're super calm for now.
The more heads we bury, the...
Yeah, the more aggro.
Yeah, the more crazy they get.
Alright, we just need to find another...
Do you think we'll be able to find more heads or is that it for now?
I don't know.
We need to find the place to bury the shovel first.
Wasn't it in the backyard?
It was this way, outside this way.
And we should be able to have a shovel like...
Around here?
Yeah, here.
We'll find more alcohol just in case.
Oh, there's a shovel!
I found a shovel!
What's this?
Oh, this is the priest.
Priest.
A little bit of priest.
Oh, I'm stuck?
That's nice, Sweeney Todd.
Yeah, thanks.
Theater nerd.
There it is.
Okay, that's the chef.
Now I know where the chef is.
Oh, that's candles.
More medkit.
There's a maid.
I found a maid!
Oh, there's a key!
Nice!
Children's bedroom!
Just in time, just in case.
Yeah.
I got cake, I got cake.
The children's bedroom has two doors.
So make sure you get both of them.
What are you looking at?
Yes, you.
It's literally you.
That's literally you.
Yeah, but there can only be one.
Okay, I got this.
Okay, nice.
Where's the other children's bedroom?
Right here, right here.
Oh, there it is.
It allows a loop.
A loop.
I have cake.
Where?
Oh, I got him.
Please.
No!
Why?
How do you...
This is a ping diff, I swear.
How are you...
How?
No!
Oh, I already had Alpha.
He's got that host latency advantage.
I know, seriously.
I just want one head.
Everybody's here for the ritual.
I got an old man.
Oh, I got the priest, I got the priest.
Nice.
Yeah, yeah, he's new.
Do you think we...
We can find more heads or is that it?
I think that's it.
There's one door that we haven't unlocked, the child's bedroom.
Oh, we've got that one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I feel like...
Oh my god, your cake is so extra moldy.
I feel like we should find more alcohol and put it down here then, just in case.
I remember seeing one...
I can go grab it.
I'm gonna go grab it.
Lime!
Oh no.
She's really eepy.
It was like...
This way.
I remember seeing it.
Around here.
There.
Oh.
Wait, we haven't gone through here?
Oh, yes we have.
This is the circle.
I got more alcohol!
I got more alcohol.
Nice.
Good job, Mint.
Thanks, Mint.
Chai, thank you for the gift.
Oh my goodness, now I'm tired.
Thank you for the super chat.
I have alcohol here.
Yeah.
Alright, I mean we have three, that should be...
Should be good.
Wait, we have one, two, three, four, five...
We need two more, I guess?
I guess, yeah.
I think that's fine, right?
Oh wait, then there's also... this one's filled, so...
Yeah, I think we just need one more.
We just need one more, yeah.
Oh my god.
This is the strat.
Oh, there's one right here.
Oh, wow.
We got all the alcohol.
The wedding is back on.
Oh, okay.
Asleep.
The crows will take them, yeah.
But there will be as soon as we put on a couple.
I feel like we should just put them on now.
I feel we should get the other shovel and then one person puts it on and the other person...
Like, we go in pairs.
Okay.
I don't know, I think there's only one shovel.
Oh, there's a cake upstairs that I put up there.
Hold on.
We're ready!
We're ready to put some...
Get a grab a head.
Mine's a priest.
Mine's the redhead lady.
Mine's a gigachat, I guess.
Let's find yours first then, maybe.
Since we don't know what he's like.
He's got, like, facial hair.
Is that the groom?
It looks totally different, yeah.
Alright, let's figure it out.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Guess who?
Is he middle-aged?
Do you have facial hair?
Buzzcut...
Or buzz... sides.
Okay, that's a lady.
That's a lady over there.
Oh no, that's a little boy.
If someone still has the ring bearer, that would be them.
Is there bodies here?
It might be this guy here.
Oh, try it.
Yeah, try it.
This head does not belong here.
Oh my god.
Honestly, it don't matter.
It doesn't matter.
I know.
I think it's at the other side.
It's the other side.
This is my lady though.
I have her.
Should I bury her?
No, I'll grab her back.
It's fine.
Don't worry about it.
We'll get her later.
Well, let's find Limes first.
I like that you can just take it back.
Actually, I changed my mind.
You can't have that.
I've grown attached to her, honestly.
Oh, who's here?
Oh, that's the chef.
So, it's a wedding.
We have to find the...
It has to be the wedding area.
I have no idea who this fucking guy is.
He's not the priest?
Is it this guy?
Oh, maybe this guy.
What is this?
Oh Jesus!
What is that?
What is your job?
What is your duty?
It might be a gardener.
Oh, it's a gardener.
Yeah, it's this guy.
No, it's this guy here.
It's literally this guy right here.
It's this guy.
Yeah, it's this guy.
Go!
Berry!
This is what you've been training for, boy.
This is it.
I'm so proud of you.
Priest!
We can stun her though.
We can stun her.
Yeah.
Wait!
He just took my head!
Someone just...
Oh.
Wait, why did I see it all of a sudden then?
That was weird.
She sounds so close.
Let's just run through here.
Is she this way?
Right here!
Okay, if I see her, I'll get her.
I got my guns blazing.
I'm ready to kick her ass.
Oh, just kidding.
Nice!
Oh, wait, she's got red eyes, you guys.
She's got...
Oh!
Why is it...
What's going on on my screen?
What just happened?
Wait, why did that happen?
Oh, I have allow transparency on.
That was like my gaming screen, you guys.
That was so funny.
Oh!
There's a head right here!
We gotta get a cake!
So funny.
I'm guarding him.
Yeah.
Sometimes the door creaks are scary.
Sorry.
She's been pulling you into that the whole time.
No way!
She's joining the cafe.
Oh, he's right here.
Here he comes.
Slow and steady.
You should do it closer so we can...
So we don't have to wait so long.
Oh, he's in the ghost world.
What the hell?
I'm body blocking you.
I'm not letting you through.
Oh, dammit!
No!
Alright.
Alright, I'll go wash the head.
We need to find the other shovel.
I think it's only one shovel.
No, there's definitely two.
Oh my god, is my thing useless?
There's two more.
I have one as well.
We all have three.
Next wave.
She's faster than you run.
Than how fast you run.
It sucks.
I'm wondering if we're supposed to stun her...
Then turn our flashlights off and hide or something.
I don't know.
Watch out!
I have...
Did someone take the baby head?
I have the baby head.
I have the maid.
Yeah, I have the maid.
You have the chef.
Alright, let's go.
Uh oh.
I think we still gotta go though.
Yeah, we gotta go.
I think she just gets angry, you know?
Every so often.
Yeah, she has a little temper tantrum.
She just gets angry sometimes.
Oh, ouch!
Thank you.
She's out here.
She's out here, I think.
There she is.
Yeah!
A run!
Run!
I think I'm dead again.
Oh my god.
Oh no!
Wait, I have...
I have this guy, I think.
Ok, where's the shovel?
Oh, I got it.
Who's laughing?
Oh, it's Stuffy.
Ok.
Alright.
Little rat.
Yes!
4 out of 10!
Oh my gosh.
This lady...
You have the maid.
Ok.
Yeah, where's the maid?
I think it's on...
I haven't seen the maid.
Ok.
Just run.
Wait, who's this?
That's the ring, or the child.
Go!
Ok.
Protect me!
What the hell?
They did not protect me.
You need a spade.
Without the jump scare sound, it's so funny even.
Oh my god, she's so aggroed.
Maid down!
While we were saving the maid...
I lost my life for the maid.
She sounds like she's upstairs.
I'll go check.
I think she's upstairs.
Oh my god.
The maid was you.
Hey, why are you leaving me?
Wife!
Wife, please!
I know you're into...
I know you're into taller men, but how a short king can treat you well!
Wife!
Don't be angry!
I know I lied on my profile, but...
But it's only a few inches!
Please!
I know I said I was 6'3"...
But I promise I'll treat you well!
I'll treat you well!
Hi!
Thank you!
Yeah, get that guy.
Yeah, I'm gonna find a cake and maybe we can get more...
Oh, easy.
Who died so fast?
Head?
Any head?
Doki dead?
Hello!
Yeah, I'm alive.
Wait, there's a head in here?
Where is he?
Oh, I see him.
Drop.
I don't know!
Oh, watch me get this head in front of you.
You can't grab it.
Oh my God!
Somebody's head!
Oh God, I'm so in trouble.
I think she's coming after me.
Am I OK down here?
Waterboard!
Am I OK?
I think that's Doki, right?
I got the flower girl.
I can't do this.
Wait.
Who is coming here?
Who is this?
Speak!
Oh, hi.
I got you.
Alright.
I just got the water girl.
Water girl?
The flower girl?
I saw a bird carrying a head.
No, we did do the ring boy.
It was like... I think it was the chef?
The crow took the chef.
Yeah.
Fire boy.
Water girl.
Right here.
You think we can do it?
She's... Wait!
Wait!
I know where... Oh wait.
We have to go through.
OK.
I'm going back.
But we have no way out.
We gotta go.
OK.
She chased her.
Let's go.
No!
I'm... Oh.
OK.
She's gone.
I'm a little like... I think she's out here actually.
Oh.
Right here!
Doki?
Oh.
Oh shit.
Can you get the shovel?
Come here, Snuffy!
Come here!
Hi!
It's inside!
Can you get this one?
Yeah, it's inside.
I've seen it kind of going around a little bit.
Goodbye, child.
Sweet dreams.
Little baby.
That's a...
She's right there.
She's...
I'll take... Turn around!
What happened to Doki?
She's dead.
Oh.
I grabbed a medkit.
I can go get her.
Somehow.
Oh.
Sorry.
Sounds like she doesn't want to be found.
I don't see her.
Are you hiding?
Oh, sorry.
I'll go in here and I'll hide.
Good idea.
What is this?
There's Doki.
More cake.
I need to get inside.
Wait, I can help you!
Whoever is crawling down.
I can help you.
You found two heads?
Oh shoot.
I know where cake is.
Let me go grab some.
I'm gonna grab cake.
Grab the cake.
I don't know!
She's coming for you.
I'm gonna shut the door.
Oh who's here?
Come on in!
Oh my god.
Maybe it was a mistake.
He's so loud.
Snuffy, where did you die?
It's right by the altar.
The shovel is right by the altar outside.
Should we go?
She's not mad anymore.
She's not?
No, she's not screaming.
Oh yeah, you're right.
Where's the shovel?
Ok, I'm trying to find the shovel.
I'm gonna go into the other realm.
Oh, when did that happen?
In the garden somewhere, she freaked out and beelined straight to me through four rooms in a garden.
What?
Oh, hello.
Uh oh.
Oh god.
I heard that there were heads.
I killed the head, I killed the crow, it dropped the head, then three more crows came in and started pecking the shit out of me.
No!
I'll go find a medkit.
Medkit, medkit.
There's gonna be one right here.
There's gonna be one...oh gosh.
Guys, I told you nobody ever defeats this game.
Oh my god, it's both of them.
No one ever truly beats Devour.
I've never seen anyone beat this game before.
This game is just way too hard.
Is that Doki?
Oh my god.
Nobody defeats...nobody beats Devour.
I got the head though.
I'm gonna go back in here.
I have the shovel!
Or I have the...
I'm gonna die!
I'm gonna die.
Goodbye world!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, I'm out of...oh my god, there's a medkit.
Oh, I'm the next time.
Dang it!
It's up to you Doki!
Streamers don't have time?
I think that comes from someone who has never played Devour before.
I'd rather...OK, you can probably beat it.
It's just the game only wants you to play it in the way that the game wants you to play it.
The game is like...you can't have any other way of playing it except the way we want you to play it.
Is Doki alive?
No, I guess so, because three people are down, but we haven't gone back to the lobby yet.
I'm gonna go...I'm gonna...
Oh my god.
Oh, that's it.
Yep.
Oh my god, new ending!
New ending!
I like that one more actually.
That one was funny.
Oh, we got a ritual token!
Nice.
What is this game?
We literally...we did the exact same thing as before and we died the same way, but we thought we were so much more prepared.
What did we know that's not true?
I died to the crows.
I died a different way.
No way, to the crows!
You couldn't kill them.
They were literally like endless.
I just watched them like plague you like a freaky...
You were swarmed.
She also, like, Mint stunned her and then ran away and then she literally just like speed hacked into Mint.
Yeah, and she even did the thing like, I'll get you next time.
So I was like, oh, I'm safe.
And her eyes weren't red, so it didn't really look like she wasn't gonna keep going, but she was just like, actually, bye.
Actually, lol.
She was red on my screen, so I think it's also kind of buggy.
Oh my god.
You know what?
We did really well, guys.
I think we did.
I think we did really well.
I think we did as well as we could.
We just didn't have any perks, so you can't blame us.
We just didn't have any perks.
Yeah, I only just got a perk now.
Oh right, there's perks in this game.
I still can't actually do anything with the perks.
It's greyed out.
Yeah, actually I was trying to click on it.
It wasn't letting me.
Yeah, I don't think we have perks.
Oh wait, I turned it on.
I'm gonna spend my perk on an emote instead.
Oh my god, this is... This is all about the grind.
It's about the grind, for real.
Wait, there's hiding spots?
There was no hiding spots?
It's like UV charge regen.
Oh, it's for the spider lady.
Because the fucking manor did not have hiding spots for sure.
Yeah, maybe the other maps like make more sense and we accidentally just went in on like...
The equivalent of level 15 people for some shit.
No, I do remember some of the maps had like closets you can hide in.
No, it doesn't.
That's what I'm saying.
The spider, the spider manor.
Yeah, but people were saying the manor was like different from how they usually do.
So I think they got rid of the hiding spots for the manor.
I don't know why.
Oh, because this game wasn't more... It was too easy.
It was too easy.
It's a sick fucking joke for getting rid of the hiding spots.
It was not easy.
I remember struggling so hard on the end.
I remember the fucking spiders.
Yeah, I know.
What are the spiders?
What's the lore with that?
There's a giant spider lady that's gonna fucking eat you and then instead of crows is other spiders that try to attack your ankles.
Ew.
You like try to gobble your ankles.
Honestly, that kind of sounds fun for next time maybe.
Yeah, I'm glad I don't have to fucking pass out right now.
I know.
We'll let Lime sleep.
I'm so ready.
I was like, Lime, are you okay?
And you just stare out into the space and I'm like, she's not okay.
She's not okay.
Let Lime sleep.
I'm trying really hard to be okay.
No, don't.
She's like 21 hours awake.
I like how Lime bought the movement speed increase perk already.
I'm ready to go fucking fast.
Oh my god, you really did already buy it.
She already bought the movement speed after getting fucked over by the bride because we were too slow.
I know what I'm gonna buy then.
You can't use your fucking perks to buy emotes.
Oh my god, I can flex.
How do I show off this?
The movement speed increased by 25% when pursued by a Zazel.
How do I show off my...
Pursued by a Zazel?
Which one is a Zazel?
Isn't that the demon?
That's the bride.
Yeah, the bride.
What the fuck emote did you buy?
I bought finger guns.
There's one where...
Oh my god.
How do you do emotes?
Wait.
You have to get in game for that.
Oh, I see the finger guns.
This is the one I bought, right?
I see it.
I see the finger guns.
How do I buy them?
You have to scroll down to the emote.
Oh, I see buy now.
Oh, I should've bought this one.
And you have to scroll all the way down for the perks.
Like, you can just scroll all the way down.
You can use your perk palismans to buy it.
The other one.
Wait, so there was a finger gun that I didn't need to buy.
Oh, this one, yeah.
Oh, I got the draw gun.
Oh, wait, the finger gun is so much better.
Oh, you did buy the finger gun?
You have to win a game in a hard mode as Sam to get the finger gun.
Nevermind, I hate this game.
You can barely do normal, guys.
GG's though, I had fun.
Yeah, so much fun.
The voices, they're gone, they're gone.
By the way, Min, you're muted.
You're muted, so we can't hear you.
And Lime is still disassociated, so she's deafened.
She's just staring at her monitor.
And Lime...
Undeafened.
Let her sleep, it's okay.
Oh, there we go.
I thought you guys just ditched me.
I was like, well, that was...
The voices were echoing, so we were like...
No, I was deafened and I just completely forgot we were in Discord.
I was like, I guess that's it, I guess they just left or whatever.
That was fun.
Yeah, it was fun.
Yeah, no, next time, we just gamer it.
And we win.
Easy peasy.
Spiders.
I'm ready to face the spiders.
Me too.
Oh my gosh, we just have a whole Devour Marathon.
A whole Devour Marathon where we never beat the game.
We never beat the game ever.
We just lose over and over again.
Double ways to die, the game.
We can YouTube the ending, someone who bought all the perks.
I wish I knew, I would've just bought them to start with.
You have to like earn the little things.
You can't pay to win?
No, you can't pay to win perks, you actually have to earn them for each year playing.
So they hate fun.
They really do, yeah.
That's why they want us to play, so we keep having fun.
That's the whole point.
I wish I could hit that woman with a shovel.
The ghost, the ghost, not Doki.
You can say Doki.
Yeah, you can say.
I've just encountered so many croquis, like I deserved it.
Thank you for playing.
We'll see you next time.
Bye-bye.
Nice.
That was a time.
That was a time, wasn't it guys?
Thanks for the streaming though, thank you guys!
I can turn myself back to normal volume now.
Thank you, thank you guys!
That was silly.
I liked that one.
It's just way so many steps.
I mean, that's how always...
Devour is.
But this one is crazy.
Have the...
First you find the...
First you get the cakes, then you find the heads.
Then you purify the heads, or clean the heads.
And then you take the heads to the thing.
And then you bury the heads and...
Oh my gosh!
I feel like it needs to...
You can't just be done with four people.
I feel like it needs to be like 15 people.
15 people to get done.
I am going to go...
To sleep.
Cause I am tired.
10 kajillion steps the game.
I know, right?
I've never seen a completed game of Devour.
Me neither!
Thanks for the fun collab, Devour was really hard.
But you all had some great teamwork tonight.
I know it's like a lot of prep before you start, but...
There are some things that you can't do...
Until...
Like, like...
Like, I think we had to unlock more heads by burying people.
And then once you start burying them...
That's when it all ramps up, so...
And by like five heads, it feels like you're on level 100.
Like, it's crazy.
It's so crazy.
But, yeah.
Ippii meant...
I'm Ippii!
I had to...
I had to wake up early this morning...
Cause I had an early...
Veterinarian appointment for Butaro.
And he's okay.
He has to wear the cone of shame.
Cause he has a little cut on his arm.
And he has to have medicine on it.
Chumura!
Look at the membership, thank you!
Thanks for the fun collab, thank you!
Thank you guys, sorry I couldn't read chat so much the whole time.
But basically, his...
Today's appointment was just a checkup.
And so, the doctor said that he's doing alright.
Yeah, the vet doctor.
The cat doctor.
And then next week I have to take Paz.
Next week I take Paz...
For her checkup.
So...
Yeah.
Oh my kittens.
But, um...
Yeah, and then I was like busy doing other stuff today, so...
But it was fun!
Today was fun.
If I see you guys tomorrow, I'll see you tomorrow.
I might have to change some stuff with Metal Gear on Saturday.
Um...
Essentially, to kind of explain.
So Vmuse is this weekend.
And, um...
I have...
Soundcheck?
That, uh, on Saturday night.
And then I have a meet and greet at 3am mine time.
And then I have to perform at 7am my time.
So I'm like, when am I gonna sleep?
I'm not sure when I'm gonna sleep.
So I might have to move Metal Gear to maybe Sunday or Monday.
Yeah.
Uh...
I'm flying to Malaysia tomorrow.
Oh, wait for the concert?
No way.
Oh my gosh.
See you there!
Yeah.
Sleeping is more important.
So I will figure out when I'm gonna do it.
And make an end post about it.
So, um...
It's been Sunday the last few weeks.
Sunday is best.
If I am not too tired...
I might be able to perform and then sleep and then wake up and stream.
I'm not sure.
I'm not quite sure.
Schedule says Sunday anyway.
It's a mistake!
It's a mistake.
Yeah.
So I was like, hmm...
I don't think...
Well, I didn't know what time the meet and greet would be until after I made my schedule.
So, um...
I thought that maybe if I even started Metal Gear a little bit earlier, I'd be okay.
But...
Yeah.
Accidental prediction.
So...
But, uh...
I think this is like my last big event.
Well, rather event on the other side of the world.
So...
For this year.
I think.
There will always be more Saturdays for Metal Gear.
Yeah.
But yeah.
Anyway.
What event is this?
It's called Vmuse.
It's a concert that I will be doing in...
In Malaysia.
But there's also a streaming ticket.
So...
I saw the AWA announcement.
Oh yeah!
Well, there's...
I think...
If you're not going to AWA...
You might...
Want to see if you can.
Is all I'll say.
Is all...
I will say.
Yeah, yeah.
Big, big stuff.
The Anime Week in Atlanta?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I hope one day I'll be able to go to a meet and greet.
But I don't know that will ever happen.
In the meantime, I hope it goes well.
Thank you.
If you ever...
If I ever get to meet you at a meet and greet...
You have to tell me what your name is though.
You have to say it out loud to my face.
But yeah.
There's a...
Definitely cooking for...
And also...
I think...
AWA has the...
Hololive concert, so...
There's that.
And then there's...
Other stuff.
It'll be a very...
Packed weekend.
A very, very packed weekend, I think.
I would in a heartbeat.
Okay, good.
Oh gosh.
Anyway.
Okay.
Otsumito, everybody.
I'm gonna go rest.
Even though I've been drinking this coffee.
I've been sipping on it.
My name is John.
John Doe.
See you at Vmuse.
Maple, if I don't see you at the meet and greet...
I better see your ass there, okay?
For real.
Call me a snake.
No, that is not a solid snake.
I better see your ass there.
Akidoki!
Oh my gosh.
You guys, I'm so excited...
For...
Halloween.
Only three more weeks...
Until I get to finally use...
I get to transform.
Call me Deepthroat.
Who are you?
One of your fans.
3.0 Minto.
And other stuff.
I'm planning a lot for the debut.
Not everything will be finished, unfortunately.
But I will be able to at least share...
Everything, too.
3.0 Minto kinda rhymes.
It does!
Minto 3.0.
Exciting times.
I'm so excited!
Oh my gosh.
I've been working on stuff everyday for it.
Things are being prepped.
And my team is working hard, too.
Okay, for real.
I'm gonna go.
Sorry, I didn't get to talk to you guys at all.
So I'm like...
Kind of in a yappy mood.
But I'll yap tomorrow.
Maybe on Saturday we could do like a...
Well, maybe I'll do something else instead of...
Metal Gear.
Maybe like a shorter...
Kind of stream.
Maybe like a hangout or something.
Good night!
Thank you so much for the dono!
Thank you!
Saturday we'll still do something.
I just, you know...
My name reflects my true feelings.
We are too comfortable in this community, maybe.
Excited for 3.02.
Good luck, Minto.
Thank you.
Okay, I'm gonna leave now.
Turquoise woman yapping, my beloved.
Okay, bye bye!
Bye bye, bye bye!
Bye bye, bring back shame.
Bye bye, OtsuMinto!
Thank you guys!
Thank you!
See you!
Good night, good night, good night.
Bye bye!
Devil may cry tomorrow.
Let's go!